what I haven't seen Big Mike for a while
I just can't wait to give him a little
smile you know oh my god
it's seriously woman's last time you got
your eyes to know you've been looking a
little personal oh these are all fixed
we'll have a dam now I see them you
bloody magic know what I'm trying to
come in some bright my oh yeah hey look
at him with my baby just walking around
her like she's being trainer TV she's
looking rough
yeah I lazy here die same pitch over
here right oh yeah
yeah she got to get a grip they show on
the TV that the slot machines are
getting all her money she really went
weighed that really needs to be all
about her kids that's not what she's
about anymore and now we just found out
that the tow truck driver got shot and
is dead yeah yeah I mean I don't know if
it had anything to do with them but June
is not in a safe place I need to go over
there and just snatch her up and bring
her back it's gonna be dangerous I don't
think she's good yeah I need you to go
with me
Gino don't run with the crowd like
you're used to running with you know van
you just can't go around actually butts
damn question I didn't go thank you -
damn pollies and you just anymore walk
out of there
regardless I'm leaving tomorrow
sorry I just can't go with it but her
life might depend on it
[Music]